hi Dave Foley I'm here for Philadelphia
forever now I played a role in that
people in that that's basically why I'm
here tonight and have always you have
the question the other question is how
does an actor keep themselves busy
between projects what's the best thing
for them to do well between projects I
like to watch a lot of television and
salt and fall into a deep depression
that usually takes up enough time then
usually work comes along or that I walk
my dog or sometimes I pay attention to
my daughter well you know because if
you're making a joke of it but anyone
who's an actor can actually see a lot of
truth in that so what does someone do to
get themselves out of that funk if the
phone doesn't ring I mean really the
only thing that gets you out of that
funk isn't working then you get more
work and you know or fine just finding
something that's fun to do creative like
I like in my downtime I started doing
stand-up again and that sort of a chance
just get out when you're bored and get
on stage and talk to people that you
know finding something that you can
create yourself kills the damn time and
what's the best advice to keep yourself
motivated for a sort of longevity I
think the part of LA is not getting
jaded a part of being successful here
what do you do you have a mantra or is
it just day at a time what do you do to
kind of keep yourself from not getting
to that place I get just the notion that
that that if you work at all in this
business it's a huge blue
you know so I I tend not to be terribly
ambitious or focused on ambition suppose
he's gone well you know if you get to do
anything in the end entertainment it's
pretty lucky so just try and enjoy the
things you get to do and you know hope
that more stuff comes alive today we
don't take it too seriously but still be
professional yeah wouldn't take it too
serious because it's a really stupid
thing to be doing for a living and face
it it requires almost no skill so you
know enjoy what comes along all right
thank you